evacuation announcements please note
this meeting will be audio recording can
we required your back way in the
buildings if these in the room by the
doors of the fire escape step please
hold boat and melding says bassist
there's a wet or slippery you've anyway
his name was user stairs they created
out of sweat the move before they go to
the fire kept all week and then you
giving asleep assembly point for me in a
public car parked at the side of the
Civic sweet please no delay of
evacuation by clicking longings and
finally please not returning to building
until your permission to do so by
council stuff okay turn to the agenda
apologies for absence Idol person
apologies we bounces hater er do and
butcher let me burn apology now mini to
the meeting held on the fifth of genuine
our members attending castle medics
what minutes of the meeting on the
pillars of January and then you've only
got any comments or objections or
cognitive abilities I'm fine
any declarations of interest see I
entitled by choosing management strategy
stable amely investment strategy and
we'll move move move provision policy
statement 2016 20 s and 70 do you mind
good evening everyone hurts my name drop
any I work for Essex County Council I'm
here on behalf of denise marie tonight
to cover her she's currently section on
Python for Watford and assisted by by
Matt here from roxford so I'm trying to
answer as many questions as i can but
you'll find out between us clearly so so
before i start i won't go through the
report line by line i'll suggest first
with there's any questions various
anything ling tricks you want me to
focus on first bother me just read it
out is there anything you can do items
used to draw attention and so i believe
that was a cup of queries we would
received or thought about earlier on
which was around object already cruise
out which were there's a question around
where the capital receipt had come from
in table 3.2 or 70 1000 pounds and we
can confirm that is from a council
property that was sold this year it was
part of the deal look at it right with
the wendy has on subjects and split off
that we would retain certain elements if
how these were sold of this nature one
of these houses what's that's that's a
slice of that sir okay yep all right
there's a second piece of go spoke to
witches around the investment strategy
which was about understanding a little
bit more about some of the actual
investment types that have been
lightened in this report
hmm i'm happy to solve another funny
noises yeah okay yep some people we do
general if I may when you do go through
that list I'd like to know please those
ones which are trading and those which
are deposits to maturity so you have
folding all right okay as I understand
it can be relatively what can be
short-term two or three years yep it can
be 10 to 15 years could be 50 years
getting to be longer actually so if if
the value of that guilt started to fall
yep on them up to market basis then you
the decision would have to be made as to
whether to dispose of it yes and take a
loss or at a certain point maybe you
supposed to take a careful profit
certainly receive the dividend so I'd
like to know as we go through those and
some of them i don't recognize directly
which ones are traded and therefore a
risk of market movement and Martha
market risk yeah and those that aren't
and are effectively deposits to material
absolutely advocate now I appreciate it
so I think the first two on there's a
fairly fairly standard sub tournament
tournament called deposits so in effect
and these are where you have quite a
fixed amount with a with a bank or
Building Society in effect it's sort of
running the mill high street type stuff
obviously you know you will get an
interest right return on it but then
they're going to be fairly low and these
will be in the majority of these cases
will be fixed actually are going to be
trying to be in that sense an investment
with a registered provider so this is
where we think about things like could
we invest in something like a housing
association so if we took example of
something like people he trusts could we
look into investing anything like a bond
or
a commercial paper or something like
that they can come up with now clearly
in terms of risk and return that's it
that's the sort of the higher end of the
risk spectrum for us bear in mind son
I'll take people use an example it's an
ia to rated investment or credit
worthiness should I say so it's still up
there in the you know the highest
bracket under the Moody writings but
it's clearly still at risk for us so but
from that would generating some
reasonable returns can't quite
percentages one pair but it is something
we would look at okay it starts with
clarification acceptor a lead or not
track it I would say that would be not
rated at the moment I think thank you
some air further on to that then
investment in property based funds so
basically how us and partners would get
together to invest in future property so
not so not necessarily a through housing
association but how would be invest
ourselves through a fund that very much
is not traded there is a risk on that
clearly because it's a much higher risk
but it get much much bigger return that
time we're just starting to scratch the
surface on to be honest with you and all
and looking at it if we're thinking
about actually probably less than one
year in bed so I called that's going to
be really pushing it for that type of
thing so I think that's certainly when
the outer fringes for us to look at so
it doesn't sound to be included
and we've then got things like the phone
of whatever we got UK government guilts
and Treasury bills and even we go into
government bonds so these are obviously
much much safer investments these are
the sorts of things where you know
you're backed by the UK government so
absolutely the risk on them is very very
hard you mean a school in effect that
Martin clearly what that means is the
return is extremely low and again the
problem we have on these is that the
returns are going to get on something
that's less than one year it's going to
be failing in the school but it's it's
still worthwhile doing it's still better
than if we look into a bank so now would
they be traded or not yeah yeah no they
are suppose they would okay just come so
i'll just clarify something that no you
talked about putting them into a
one-year guilt take effect okay it
depends yeah and there's a bit later on
about how much we work on to potentially
putting across we want to manage that
portfolio clearly and when you talk work
and how to available so as a bit of a
mixture so and we gone so i'm on a
general note took pointer for my is
there any possibility that any
investments could be made overseas my
thinking of that is we don't want there
to be a nice than type situation and we
would controller who there makes a
decision as to whether we invest don't
invest with coming i know we use capital
for instance yeah but we don't always
follow their leader further advances so
who within our DC actually wouldn't make
the decision as to whether
reversed or to come out that amazement
it would be under I think 10 sexy 15
months Sheldon I think that's what the
paper would recommend ok so its place
within the limits of this paper yes ok
take into account the advice of other
office oh yeah absolutely yes that's
right been about a portfolio holder the
revival of a takeover of the ice that
dunk now agree don't so I'm not fast
enough to the Rochford's so the object
to disguise the long flyball office
doing the thought said yes
okay then we come to things like things
are banks and supranational National
Bank so these are things like the
European European Development Bank and
things like that we're actually you'll
get a slightly better return for some of
their investments but clearly it's still
not going to be a fantastic return that
you would get off a very very high yield
high-risk investment but that is much
more fluid we would be able to get some
liquid liquid funding from the Adelaide
we could then look at some stuff like
commercial papers and corporate bonds
corporate bonds are all risky and SMS
them are over one year but it's
something we shouldn't discount
certainly I don't think we'll be doing
it this year but something the future we
could be looking at commercial paper is
the same as a corporate bond but
actually less than a year but then
you're talking again a high-risk
strategy and in fine is where we are at
the moment which is where we use the
standard money market funds which is
basically what's being used currently
Rockford and from that although we get a
a level of returning certainly not
sweating our assets and not making the
best use of the funding we do have
available but inside I bought you this
question above all of these which is how
it's always the same risk is and how the
liquid r us it's how quickly can we get
to our funding what's the level of
return vs what is the level of risk
we're willing to accept now clearly some
of these are quite knowing quite
innovative for Oxford so we need to
decide actually we think that's the
right way to go where we want to go for
a much more safer version but therefore
it's jeopardizing the potential
opportunities there for yourself
just add to that mean clearly we do have
limits on what we can invest than we do
make sure we learn the investing some
weighted funds bodies investments bite
on their credit rating and we do use the
capita color coding as much as we can to
give us an idea about duration in terms
of them the credit rating is I
understand how they're set I understand
how caprica do it as a professional
investor service I seeing that there is
no credit scoring done by any officer
Roger district cats are indeed the 151
officer not miss Harry's I wouldn't be
an expert in it to them and no one and
there is no no one at all in the council
that will override a credit rating given
by capita correct but mixing
it comes to the point I suppose children
where I think I where I came in and we
spoke about mark mark mark to market
risk but of course you can only do if
its market traded something like a
investment in a local or national
housing association you wouldn't know
day to day whether it was in good shape
or not he wouldn't know whether he tried
to raise a bond and he had gone flat you
really wouldn't know what political
effects were likely to come and hit
housing associations and indeed they
have food so that risk is there I guess
what I'm getting to is Bali those are
real high risks as you said the market
risk is a market risk we have seen
guilts and other traded interest rate
instruments falling price in the last
well the last three weeks ever since
China started to fall and other markets
when same way you raised in the paper
the situation where presumably would be
biking to market on a daily basis and if
a if a traded instrument was as I
Brazeau underwater showing a loss then
it's an immediate decision for council
offices to make to the side walls don't
absolutely so how would you go about
that what to be fair we can have to use
our advisors of chapter to be honest
that's what they're there for us what we
found in there for so they should be
able to give us that advice and its then
on our court whether we think so it's
going to be on a case-by-case basis
looking at each of the portfolio items
and sound where'd we think the risk is
and then some what is the working
capital need over the next day 16 months
six months six weeks and so on and then
work out what is the level of risk we're
going to take on that investment because
I know on some
what investment houses and interest rate
traders do why do you think it council
should start to get involved in
effectively trading because what we're
talking about on a mark-to-market basis
and making those sort of day-to-day
decisions albeit with investment advice
is we're training why would we do why we
wish to do that and why is it
appropriate thing for a local authority
to do with essentially residents month
even these also a situation that says we
have reducing funding envelopes
increasing pressure and therefore we
have to look at other ones to try and
maximize the return on our assets and
unfortunately have money just sitting in
the bank account doesn't do it anymore
so it's not there now what we are
proposing hopefully we are proposing
anyways anything that's that's it on the
risky strategy end of you know of
Icelandic banks again we're now talking
this stuff it's been proven I agree some
of the property stuff maybe we need to
look at again on I'm not going to hold
ourselves dear to that but certainly
something like gills since I'm like
Treasury bonds and things like that are
relatively safe so why shouldn't we be
trying to return as much as we can so
therefore we put this less pressure on
our residents in the other way I thought
there's a risk to biodegrade there's a
risk of both sides explain to me things
chill if I may continue with this line
if we invested six million pounds in
gilts then on recent events how much
could they fluctuate by in terms of
volatility I'm fine in other words you
don't have on the private
that's a that's worrying me now because
you know you we should we here should be
thinking well could we lose 600,000
pounds overnight half a million quid and
we could have an officer making a
decision to either run it or lose
another 400,000 or we could close it and
minimize our loss there's always that
risk isn't there in a balanced market
and I'll declare I have home managed
trading rooms so I'm fully aware of what
can happen even in TBS I once had a
trader that was trading Treasury bills
and he lost to two million quid wouldn't
stop to ask him to lose to move to go
which was a little bit embarrassing so
these are real risks I think I want to
see market volatility before I made any
decision on trading investments and
those investments that are not traded I
think I'd be more worried about
Thank You mr. Chen I'm quite interested
in how you say that you're going to
respond to the volatility in the market
you're saying that you're getting the
information from capoten but are you
relying on them to contact you when
something goes well do you have daily
updates do you have I mean the markets
can learn very very quickly and I don't
anticipate and I'm sure none of this
would the section 151 officer sitting
there watching markets on a daily basis
therefore are we expecting you to do
that are you contacting them or I mean
where does the initiative come from they
want from you yeah I can step in that
phone we are notified via credit watches
as soon as an institution is put on
either negative or waiting watch
instantly my captor and we have a weekly
relationship meeting with our
relationship manager captures or a wire
conference conference call okay can't
just come back there beautiful so that's
on the negative side yep about the
positive side that would tend to come
out more in the weekly meeting okay okay
you think just lay off from them SMC's
Mason with capture that I we're under a
pretty low level contract with the
character which I think last you or
6,000 pounds a year would this change of
policy because these are changing
investment policy would that mean we
would have to pay for more or increase
service or not audit we don't we don't
think something among Germany an example
I can give is that the the level of
advice given to in my role or in the
in essex county council what they get
from their treasure classes is a lot
more forest for a relatively similar
level of funding so actually we don't
think we're actually don't think we're
probably getting enough at mark from
Kappa that's what I'm going to stock in
what was in starting me know the next
few aches to talk them through see what
else they can do it to be a bit more
proactive here so that you can start to
build up again and actually said what
else can we get for the same double your
fun okay no absurd ganglion well I just
antsy when you and you said you know you
love that familiar with obviously we've
only recently taken over from the lease
and this does calls me something so no
other the audience chatting to I know
about not with you as an individual but
the situation that we have 14 11 51
officer and we have you the best with
the best will in the world in three
months time we might have another one I
have no idea and I become very uncertain
about the lack of consistency I i'll be
honest I i I've done don't know your
track record about working in trading
scenarios when I was a trailer nine
money but in other areas and he he don't
just walk into it look very long
apprenticeship you get it wrong URL and
so I i I've listened to a memo and I
understand whether the strategic ideas
but I tend to follow John's view I can
do i live in my money and I can cook for
an hour anywhere that this isn't my
mother and if it does go pear-shaped
who's in do we blame how do we find a
disciple I took the advice from
Catherine but at the end of the day
you're gonna read a guy depressing the
button
if the regime change and check is not so
technical I'm afraid but I've been
listening to this and it just reinforces
an issue that i personally have in there
we are dealing with public residents
money public money and and the local
authority I've already learned it can be
quite the sort of life proactive in some
ways large is life management or
whatever you have to find their finance
& their resource and I'm just trying to
work out in my mind because someone
academically as soon as you are in terms
of money now where will these things go
which I don't profess to know he is you
think of a gun and I'm worried about is
this this investment worth the risk in
terms of the stability of our finances
of council if I must open it is that
risk important enough I'm going over our
briefs tavern fonts you don't know which
we might need I mean we're on unit money
off where are the interest of a thought
on existing money why do we need to step
that further and take that extra risk
I mean all I can say is that if if we
don't go down this not even this room if
we don't start looking at how we get
better returns from our from our money
sitting there very mind whatever that is
that is going to mean further reviews of
services we're going to have to make
we're going to have to look at how we're
funded l expected unfortunately this is
an item that we need to look at I mean
it's I appreciate your position right
but I do Sally agree with you either I
really don't want to progress that this
is a completely wild you know we've just
done often doing a bob diamond type
thing and kind of investing real high
stakes games here these the investments
that have been proposed our fairly love
level of risk items I do appreciate John
they will move and they when there will
be fluctuations but we're knowing that
such of we're not in a situation where
we want to be going to risk public the
public market absolutely not i totally
agree with that but we have to try and
squeeze our bricks it all comes down to
risk appetite what is our risk appetite
here now the moment is extremely except
one end is adversely at nil and all we
want to do is move that fight well I
don't propose we go and completely to
the other end of you know betch
capitalist type stuff absolutely not but
for me I suppose it's that the question
life again on probably arts asking is
that what at what point is that cut off
and actually I'm feeling some of these
proposals if they're not it then what is
and is it is it a zero in fact we just
go back to walk around in a half that's
fine but I do think there's probably
room for maneuver where that ends up
which this full report works at
something in the middle i don't know i
think that's my question
it's all about the risk I'm [ __ ] done
Thank You Jeremy then there could be
opportunities for the the committee to
discuss this list and decide which ones
they're prepared to take the risk on
ones that are at this point I think
we're thinking we're going to be taking
risks or our investment for what I
wasn't going to mention the investment
board investment board is actually
designed for us to make investments at
risk and to generate not just capital
returns but more particularly income
return image indices this is thing that
all about the council has to consider in
terms of the whole of the overall
portfolio having made that decision and
making decisions on the portfolio of
investment board projects over time just
how much further they want they want to
go on the face of things this is this is
lower risk but on the other hand an
accident or two here completely without
you know anybody's mismanagement just
simply 2008 happening all over again
would be would be calamitous in that
respect the public would lose complete
confidence in us and the investment
board would be something I'm sure they
would be clamoring to say close which
would be a bit of a shame really so I
think there's a there's a balance here
there's a balance that we have to
present to to the electorate ultimately
as Kansas prairie saying yes you would
be making the decision
but when it came down to it it would be
the counselors who would be taking the
cam back remember when you look at it to
those cancers that lost money out of
Iceland and other country investments
you know I'm sure we're looking for
other seats in other councils later I
want to ask another question if I may
because I just wanted to answer your
points you know in the way I felt about
things but we last year did a bit of
[ __ ] marking and because we were
sitting here as a task complete group a
year ago thinking for are we doing as
well as we should and the results we got
back we were doing as well as we show
them better than many and I suppose my
question is going to be to you have any
other councils district councils rock
county councils they're different
different beasts are actually taking
this higher risk investment approach
with council attacks I can't say I can
quote definite but i would say how many
of them have actually signed up to it i
don't know how many of them considering
out i would say probably most certain
parishes are not send some of the
smaller districts but it's a way of
looking at how you generate additional
funding without having to touch services
as for me it's a consideration we have
to take clearly it all comes down to the
risk a feline each individual area
that's it and how badly they got burned
in two thousand dr muscat I mean strike
me generally would be appropriate for a
review committee to meet some of these
councils and talk about what process
they went through internally and maybe
with the perfect to decide whether to
take this sort of risk and more
particularly if they've been doing it
for a little while just how well it's
going because at the moment we're just
taking a stabbing in there
dawn okay Sonny dinner yes I'm just
concerned about the element of risk
going you you've said this the very low
risk as we know the moment and you're
nudging yourself that it seems quite a
big much half of these that you've
mentioned a high risk okay the bucket
won't be my but the elements at high
risk the great now I would have liked to
say some figures on this and there's
grease okay in relationship to our right
in other words a penny reg is roughly
about 60,000 pounds so if we're risking
60,000 pounds we know what we've got to
do to replace that but I don't see that
in this document and I don't know if
it's possible to extract that sort of
information laughter good i think that
would be quite helpful because it would
put it in perspective for us if we would
be able to say that okay so if that one
goes belly-up we will have to put right
up by 2% going to say and i think that's
an element where we can look at the risk
in a different way that will make it
easier for us to make a decision bit
more tangible reserve is that possible
put your sony bravia thinking further
questions of this challenge I'm calling
just one question and can you reaffirm
the amount of investment we get now as
opposed to the projected investment we
will get on shall we go down the route
the investment income will this
financial year ending in March will be
in the region of 35 to 40 thousand from
this report in point 10.7 you'll see we
look into generate between 80 to a
hundred thousand sixteen seventeen by
adopting these new project of it yeah to
add to that we will also have more money
to invest as well so it's a you dublin
but on a bigger number okay so put on
based on your answer that question could
you and based on your answer to council
she's nice and could you sort of
identify where you or you believe the
increased returns would come from it
would the obvious that it's not been
bringing a visibly it's an aspiration so
that's where we're aiming for and then
we would fit our risk profile behind
that so we're we best put that clearly
if we if we wanted to invest one hundred
percent in the most risky area yet we
could generate and return far greater
than that so clearly that's not going or
to go because we have advanced the fire
so we've built an aspirational figure
the motives 100,000 and then in the
background will look at voice the right
investment profile behind reading the
report i gather that the the biggest
chunk of money was remain where he is
now effectively money mark my money
market funds so give me that and there's
an ink a lot more main being generated
from the smaller amount of money from
the riskier element which could be
governed difficulty yeah but we've also
have got more money to invest this year
and there is more money to invest that
was everything yes because that's it
basically and here's how much was
invested of them a much more is being
invested this this finally we have taken
to account we call the waste vehicles so
most about long-term investments up to a
year we look
brought back to pay for the vehicles I'm
so require at the level playing field
and down where we're building it back up
so hopefully next year we'll have two or
three million or long-term investment
okay thank you okay everybody starts
because I'm obviously pleased you say
you can have lunch on two or three
million what percentage of that or how
much of that where you could have put
into this sort of strategy you're
talking about that for some of its all
in fixed income so how much is that
you're talking about and I was wrong
figures we look at it to be honest I at
the moment you've been given our current
strategy we will put all that way in in
one year fixed rate account with someone
like Lloyd's that pays about point nine
percent for a year as and when we get to
have those amount of funds we'd have to
sit down and decide where we're going to
split it and how we would split it up
against waiver criteria agreed upon a
committee the only time to buy or sell
questions because in the back of our
mind is sorry chairman it's just that
I'm trying to think of is just more my
ideology of your life is why don't you
just to prove a point while ng zone for
the best a small amount of money to show
an assistant words new if that works
think you could come back and saying
we're successful and I don't mind look
at what's that don't my place of the
robberies in any money see with all in a
pocket but it's better to those small
than it is to prove a point and lose
everything and so on just one room if
that fat fault hasn't even been looked
at I know you want to get the money
there you want to get a month which or
bad you know the devolution on short
sardines and test the order I feel you
know not so ambitious to it because I'm
a very cautious man if we could be
taking sorts to a degree if we talking
about point nine percent that we we
currently gay and you're talking about
going into something like government
guilds bishop of pretty safe what sort
of return you can get on
those and why I'm weird why I'm we and
everybody else done here before I then
put my knife a mold and know what
government guilt paces with them useful
moment as in when we would look at those
things that we could provide those
figures by dynamic having the party on
honey I don't no longer got the history
no I haven't that lost kid you go I feel
like I said I think it's there is
certainly a risk question I totally
agree but like say apart from and I
would make them from diamonds properly
for me that the property started and the
corporate bonds you know they've been on
the riskier end of this actually things
like guilt and and your government bonds
and socket lat let it simply say you
know militant visa nothing's ever one
hundred percent so by a great but you're
getting to a point of again of how how
much are we charging up that's the
question
robard i'm gonna say it's a little
disappointing in how I'm sure you accept
that when we're asking questions about
how much better we can do any guilt but
you're able to tell us because that
doesn't tell us what the upside is and
you know we know this downside risk will
be also in the last couple of weeks I
mean it struck me that there's one a
heck of a lot of questions with RC which
you know we need we link the council and
it's not just this committee I think the
council I take forever hi I think the
council on these answers do before this
additional risk is taken group together
so we need to you know engage in full
due diligence and you might consider
running a dummy portfolio and presenting
it to how well we'd have done or at
least you know go to capital Aaron and
ask them what market volatility applied
to who would have would have effective
us you know since the beginning of this
year and they could see some tracker
information going on this this is a step
too close to 2008 for me at the moment
even though I have the background if I
if I was able to if I were in managing
this day to day I probably wouldn't
worry so much because I've got some
experience in doing so but I don't have
that confidence at this point with the
council doing
and I'm very very nervous of doing it
with residents money I'm sorry to say it
makes me even more nervous than that I
feel with my own give you back you wish
to do now in college you want a
discussion between ourselves they're
young but I think chairman we ought to
list the information we haven't got like
and the information we'd like to have
and I think we need to talk together
about what sort of recommendation we
want to make I mean I think my head says
that if we need to make a decision on
the investment strategy soon as a
council then this paper having come here
we should probably make a decision to
keep the status quo and and invite
council to allow the review committee or
you need any other committee or
structure it wishes to to to seek
answers to the further questions we and
areas we've identified but that's for
you to you to ask the committee how we
want to do it I always could be full two
losses but
probably just felt the old ahead I think
we I think they need up perhaps if the
markets a bit more Boing over the last
of the years we wouldn't be having this
conversation we always see their second
year and the why I've lost my last
number three weeks but I don't know
anymore but it is concerning her say it
the world business is what I understand
all the all the ideas and the knees to
generate more funds isn't my money and
that is my big concern I can take the
entirely different attitude with my
money in my risk when I can with this
residence it's a simple sailing becomes
anymore I think perhaps the idea of
Jonathan if we could have some try and
run some dummy portfolio over the next
six months you know you know what we
know is a volatile market none of these
going to change anytime soon and we can
read the viewing perhaps it is John says
almost a monthly basis or quarterly
basis whatever is more appropriate I
never I think perhaps might give us more
confidence to to say but I pray yeah we
could do this on really volatile market
then if it was a little bit more
confidence to say you know we think we
can be buds but that that's pretty
personal views on
people mr. Chaubey run yeah I think
that's an excellent idea I think the
thing that concerns me is it's a
relatively long return for a
comparatively high risk that is not
really as our money to play with and I
certainly think that to keep the status
quo while we doing further
investigations would be the safest
option going forward we probably sensed
members have a degree of nervousness on
our me about this spawn I darkness shall
pray fajr very sensitive I think Pradesh
prove that proofing don't tell me you
aren't aware we want incall bit yeah
coming portfolio Dumbo do whatever
terminology will call it and you might
be very helpful the capital would do
when installing things that yeah
epidemic or volatility data they can run
anything your life no time to you I
don't want to get the idea that we're
all negativity JAMA so we you know we
have been in training world we do know
the benefits of it but we also know but
very much the it's all best of the night
downside so I need in their money this
is better about it
is Thank You mr. chairman I agree with
the idea of a dummy run dummy run I
think that's a good idea and a historic
dummy run if that's the right brace it
seems to be able to have the answer but
if we do a dummy run for the future then
obviously we've got decide how that is
made up investment wise and so that I
think is something that we should think
about it sure I agree with cancer danger
said the scenarios that we can run on
down portfolios could have different
percentages and do across the most
appropriate of these of these
instruments I think Rob's got a feeling
for the sort of instruments you know we
would we would likely to include in the
first in the first run I said they
wouldn't put housing associations or
anything where you put the money in and
hope you very buddy when you've come
back and ask them for effect you know
don't mean that geode in a derogatory
sense to our friends in housing
associations but they're not something I
know much about and I think they come on
quite high interest rates in the bond
market and they probably have a find a
bit harder to raise money at the moment
with the right to buy having come you
know see beyond me so yeah we can run a
number of portfolios members you know he
can be you know very small amount in you
know gilsum and fixed fixed deposits and
or it could be the opposite you could
turn it on its head the other way around
so you can see you know what your risk
appetite might be yeah thank you talking
wriggle to be cheap but I want you to
talk to out if it's possible and because
I don't know what I travel roaming about
so if you was looking at that i'm using
your head if you like if you in your
mind thought their much we should be
investing then i'd rather get an idea
how you're thinking and what sort of
money you're talking about investing so
when you do this book like that i would
like to say what that could turn would
have been on loss i mean i could be fair
since two thousand five years ago and
we're still bounce it a long recovery
mr. that pride of we're still looking at
they a common marquee issue we're
looking at all sorts of other things
going on and i'm not convinced we can't
have another one tomorrow or not
convinced so that's why I'm very wary
actin so it will be nice if you in your
in your way could present to us what you
think we should be invaded investing on
all of its up and agree with it but yeah
do you know what I mean what you think
reasonable and I think I'll return on
their or loss or whatever my going if I
agree with everything that's been saying
cuz I just have an issue of a risk any
further questions colleagues are you
able to do what we wish yes we can it go
when I see what we can do and come back
and can we make some other councils and
talk to them about in there yeah you
want how they went through other
districts specifically yes the
ex-champion synthesized in nature are
you only to refer today through your we
can tell you I can't talk to people have
some contacts and we can do enough can
you vote any further points colleagues
mr. chairman can I just say that if we
are going to raleigh's demi portfolios
and they can be done historically and
going future we now can we look perhaps
of three months because if it is a
positive resume I don't think we want to
wait for six months than the nuns
so can I ask that we have perhaps one
that you would recommend a slightly
higher risk their coupler lower yep
because I think from the field of
everyone here it's the lower risk that
is going to be more attractive to us but
we might see your recommendation and if
we could have that in three months time
and perhaps the historic coil as well
then we will be in a position to say
this is the facts let's discuss with a
lot more knowledge than what we have
here we haven't got the detailed
information to make a valuable and valid
decision I don't think Thank You mr.
chairman so I think my only closing
comment would be para la doing the the
dumbing portfolios would be obviously
there you'll know past trends will not
predict the future so I just don't want
to be helped with that we have two day
to day a preserve you know idea of five
percent return that absolutely that may
not happen in future so as long as i get
my comment in there that's the Germans
still project the same builder ticket
sales lately yet we can we can cash out
there yes it's obviously very easy to
make historic trends be the ones you
want I think it's important to each
other and historic funds are used
they're the ones which we use for the
next three months yeah yeah yeah yeah we
won't pick and chose you at us let's be
let's be able to do movie if you did
whatever look anyone here if you'd
accept like what you've chosen and of
course we'll know that it's a straighter
what I like to see
collingswood agrees in a portfolio that
twice to weakness hard because you've
got send out yes yeah in your paper goes
in there and wishes so excited too fine
a point on it and so the portfolio they
weren't able to do that and then we can
go call wonderful medium range or
something I was entering okay gutted
recommendations because i think you mean
copy one someone's amazon yeah
alrighty i'm investment strategy has
been approved but some of the other day
that's more after me for the rest of
your call Yeah right 23 for me yeah si
that's on things here five and come on
come join and seeks is an amended yeah
yeah it is amended but I'm just trying
to help them love going bowling and
would be helpful in this video's to all
over that you get some 234 around Kai
yep firebox you've done and six is the
menu to go back and I just wanna get on
the correct terminology young
investments trans again so would you
like me to sort of that amount of
processed wants to redraft this with the
status quo investment is to go to
counsel subsequent and then throw the
pace that says the dummy run German know
the thing we need to be convinced of the
strategy okay animal too risky because
we've then got to say the full council
yeah no I'm it was thinking that they
would lab at this yeah I main take it
back to these status quite as it no will
take you back to the states permit /
pool okay or should we are new yes
whenever there's a way and that becomes
the revenue Committee's recommendation
full council which will be returned to
the states quote pending further work
yeah you know that keeps it open and
honest and I don't need dishonest now
cuz gently transparent okay thank you
very much as well thank you
couple you better get in quick I
condition Norwich and I think I'm a
little confused because I've just been
so tied up with other things what the
one on 1515 which is on page two with
this key decision document did I not say
a decision by the portfolio holder very
reason anyone trusted man we didn't see
your waistline no County one he was
actually the chomps with local playing
there's a concert picture there's not
talking to them I had a dream ok just a
majority setback
any mother points on the PDA phones that
loses April Adrianne just the same as
last month and hopefully we should see
16 17 19 break this month and then no
one's on them item seven the work plan
which is attached the only thing of a
thread on the works and ease michelin's
farm the report on that will come to the
first of march 18 degree planning
enforcement swirl
first of all right now no there's
another one but I want to go away you go
typically talking you get tired of
vultures probably find every fit over
there with question on the article this
is Jack all right anybody points on the
work colleagues ok any other your side
try off dumb trolls of a pro fujin
lifestyle last time we have a site visit
and we start from some defects I'm keen
to go again to see whether those
defections have been but sauron other I
shouldn't snigger you came in night 23
briefing they've already asked me tell
ya I start out good boy I put this
temperature with did you wanna go around
all the four sides or just the Lanisha
pleasure because we picked up and some
queries on on that that obviously now
they change to fusion whether those
defects are still a yep um was obviously
if they are spying in as much so that
nothing's changed Jessica doesn't know
you're out there so just for my clarity
you want to go to rein in Asia and you
want to go to Clemens yes that's it
fuzzy knew I think the meal we don't see
about that will be a recently do the
kitchen was there but they have improved
upon yes
so we got back there might be fruitful
points week right yeah it in your
culture rollin why don't we go to the go
to bribe you measure and pencil and if
we become seriously twitchy and we do
some of the old minutes and i promisee
jotted it down on it going just
interested to see whether then he
changes the beam make our
recommendations okay on the other hand
the weeks until about do it so America
close to me to like to roley's goodnight
yeah very glossy yeah if he's on the fat
one is happy just 18 batters one